this is restaurant wars I have a man the
shit's getting real yeah sneaking
suspicious gonna be a no shortage up in
fries comes the bata is on the bagel you
can eat it
any time of the day cream cheese the
pizza that is nasty
yep oh that sounded awful oh yeah I am
this what is with this
so um I don't even like cream cheese in
my sushi Philadelphia Maki Ella cream
cheese
um cheese and raw fish no but um but we
haven't tried it so who knows uh yeah
yeah I'm so saying that I know for a
fact that is a bad idea
tomato sauce and cream cheese out of on
a bagel with no so Steven goes to the
fry place and no I want you to
acknowledge em right fine I don't give a
okay this is uh it's never going to
exist I shall in some ways me some of
these somebody already gonna say like
melting like somebody already has yeah
they may like the cat sandwich Ice Cream
Sandwich I'm sure victims
um but let's not saying good um so yeah
he goes and gets these mozzarella sticks
at the fry place that caused this
restaurant war between the two
restaurants and Steven has to figure out
a way to stop it and pepperoni and cream
cheese will go together
like oh can you don't even like cream
cheese so I mean it cream cheese and
anything won't go together with you
probably not um
so yeah they try to find out a way to
stop that eventually comes around -
Steven opens his own restaurant with
those disgusting smoked salmon and cream
cheese I think is as far as I'll go I
can actually do that it's good I like
cream cheese I have no power I just but
like like a tuna Maki or something with
the cream so they tried to have him shut
down the restaurant he agrees if they
stopped the war and they said overpowers
the fish are we overlooking the serious
you know big holy moment that there
actually was a slight chuckle
Rinaldo joke you left I did not
oh I I diver if I refuse to laugh ever
although I won't give him the honor I I
look Laurie I will give him two chuckles
in fact one is the girlfriend joke which
was funny you know he says I have a
girlfriend
nobody believes in so he pretends to be
going now oh no no when the other guys
said was like and where is his
girlfriend is like you were saying what
I was thinking that made me laugh
because I was like that actually was
also what I was thinking as an audience
member friend shows up and they're
watching koala he may and he loses his
girlfriend so that was funny and then I
also got a little bit of a laugh when he
says uh he says you know how did
girlfriend say he's like I'm full Oh
sadness I thought that was a little
funny to the the line I liked both was
just when they literally said shut up
Ronaldo I just I got up I applauded I
cheered it was one of the most cathartic
moments it got he cheered so loud
neighbors were you know coming over
asking if a woman was murdered
actually it's true there was like
somebody jogging outside they just
looked up at the window
probably the police are on their way um
but uh yeah it's it's cute again I like
it when they open the restaurant and
Angie Cowell you said you're like you
know what's nice and beyond saying we're
kinda like Angie what can be a good
place for a restaurant she I was like
this business plan makes sense yeah menu
is awful but I'm like great ambience
I like some gems as the you know
waitress and maybe put it like that I
feel like maybe this was a missed
opportunity because I just would have
watched that is the rhyme tirana my
friends another restaurant that's
exactly what as soon as I saw garnet
there you know what the red tie
understand everything I'm like this
veidt's comedy like this is if I know
right uh it's only like the last couple
minutes but it's like I ain't gonna like
that the whole episode is that up Ness
is again it's cute it's fine um Ronaldo
lost the love of his life folk good the
one thing
maybe a joke a lot funnier is it not
only do they have a girlfriend but it
was like a smoking-hot model beautiful
like super knockout
are you shaming that poor girl is she's
um pretty enough for you uh I'm saying
like if she was like just this absolute
she's like Jessica Rabbit like some
ridiculous exaggeration that would make
it a lot funnier because how the hell
would he get someone like that it's Wow
I mean it is it the girl race seems a
little straightening how like she's a
crying or Ronaldo pity watching
something called Kowalik you hey um so
it does make me wonder a little bit of
her story but because you watched
something called koala princess doesn't
mean you have to question it but it does
make me wonder a little bit of her story
the only thing is that means I would
invite more Ronaldo so I'm just like no
I don't know no no no no Ronaldo this
was this was just the perfect amount of
Ronaldo I got to know I as a little ass
hey no no it was a perfect amount
because he only had like five lines and
I got to laugh at his misfortune better
than that that is the Ronaldo I like
what he suffers so we are so full of
hate just pardon all that uh mr is a
little bit large um I do hope they have
another episode together whatever larger
Ronaldo gonna get together yeah finally
this will be that this is why I didn't
leave the girlfriend thing nothing is
gonna get a girlfriend cuz clearly is in
love with Lars so losing lesbian subtext
let me get ronaldo mars together in lars
our heads okay ship that ship that one
and that's it you have to call it is
Lars I'll tell you that's that's a
shipwreck waiting oh my god okay so now
I'm glad I'm really glad watch this
episode because we have in waters and
shipwrecks as far as ships go that's
like somewhere between the flying
dutchman than the goddamn Titanic oh
okay
Oh God I think we're done yeah bye
yeah